-The daily briefings are..
a circus.
A lot has been written
and said about...
whether or not they should
even be televised.
How do you -- Are you gettin
any information from them?
Do you feel as though
it's fair criticism
to say they maybe
should be on TV less?
-I mean, I think -- Yeah.
I think that the --
I mean, I think,
the critique, to me,
the concern I have
is that they often --
they literally communicate
public health information
that's wrong, or is in contrast,
or tension,
with the best
available evidence.
And that can --
That's dangerous, right?
I mean...
we know there's been
a sort of partisan divide
about how seriously
people take this,
how much they're adhering
to social distancing.
Though that's closed quite
a bit, which is good.
But that, to me,
is the real concern about this
I do think that the briefings,
as a performance,
have kind of entered their
like, baroque phase.
[ Laughs ]
The writers are out of ideas
and it's -- you know --
There was a moment yesterday
where he was --
the president of
the United States --
2,000 Americans
died yesterday,
nearly 30,000 Americans
have passed away.
The economy is contracting
at a Great Depression level.
And the president,
for three minutes,
just read the names
of companies.
-Yeah.
-Like, "Chik-fil-A --
we love Chik-fil-A.
McDonald's."
-Yeah.
-[ Stammers ]
To me, the more obviously
they are ridiculous exercise
in his own
self-aggrandizement,
the weirdly less dangerous
they become.
The earlier phases
felt more dangerous to me
because they had
the putative frame
of being a briefing from
the task force on public health.
At this point, it seems to m
that it's so obvious
that's not what's --
That's not what's happening.
-One of the biggest shifts
that is happening, as well
is this idea of reopening
the economy.
It seems like -- and again
it changes every day --
it seems as though
the president is fixating
on this idea
of May 1st.
And how much of this,
do you feel,
is driven by his fear
of a failing economy
versus his sense
that we're all safe
to go back
to our lives?
-I mean, it's 100%
the former.
The biggest mistake they mad
from the beginning --
and I talked about this
on my show last night --
was, in the beginning, when th
problem began to materialize
and manifest -- and particularly
manifest in the stock market -
the president clearly thought,
"I'm gonna run for re-election
on a great,
booming economy."
They were explicit
about that.
That's not like --
That's what they said.
And now, "The economy's
doing poorly.
It's gonna hurt
my re-election.
We need to pump
the economy back up."
And at the beginning,
they were focused on the economy
as a somehow separate proble
from the public health problem
And the thing experts kept
saying is like, "No, no, no.
They're not --
You've got to deal with
the public heath problem.
You can't just..."
And eventually, I think
he was convinced of that,
and now, is going back
to the old thinking,
which is, "Okay, now we're gonna
reopen the economy."
It's still the same
Goddamn virus.
It's the same virus that's
you know, circling around.
It's still the same thing
causing the problems
to have us lock down
the economy.
There's no independent solutio
to reopening the economy
that is independent
from a plan to deal with
and contain the virus.
-We're gonna be right back
with more Chris Hayes.
And I want to talk about the
fact that there is an election
even though no one
is talking about it.
We'll be right back.